it's the first day of the annual budget
debate and the chancellor went into it
with one big argument in the bag
germany is heading for zero new
borrowing next year for the first time
in nearly half a century
for angela mackel that marks an
important watershed in fiscal policy
it's important for our country but it's
also important for the european union
and the
eurozone germany is needed as an anchor
of stability and an engine of growth the
goal of taking on no new debt is
realistic
ukraine is another main focus
the chancellor accuses russia of
breaking international law
still she wants a diplomatic approach to
moscow as well as sanctions
but she says there's a long way to go
we're aiming to ensure the territorial
and sovereign integrity of ukraine which
is able to choose its own future no more
and no less
the opposition left party sees that
differently it describes the sanctions
as a pointless economic war with
dramatic results
you've driven germany into a renewed
cold war with russia which is poisoning
the political climate and endangers
peace throughout europe
this debate is traditionally a chance
for the opposition to attack government
policy but they're attacking a
chancellor with a very solid majority